[Music]
let every be Joseph replace you in
heaven and nature sing and heaven and
nature sing
nature's saying nice it's it's the thing
hello zzzz I'm rich Fulcher and today
we're gonna talk about how Teddy
Roosevelt's children saved Christmas
pretty cool it was 1901 Teddy Roosevelt
was just elected the President of the
United States his motto was speak softly
and carry a big dick Theodore Roosevelt
is a huge conservationist you don't want
to know he's actually I do okay
basically in his lifetime he had five
national parks 18 national monuments 150
national forests he loved those trees so
goddamn much and he thought I don't want
a tea tree cut down
I don't want Christmas trees in my White
House so Theodore Teddy was a family man
he had six kids and he loved his kids
hi I'm Archie hey I'm Quentin hi I'm
Alice I'm Theodore jr. um so he had all
these kids and he was just brimming with
see me what was that a mouth are there's
a mouth for ya what so okay so it's
Christmastime Roosevelt would dress up
the Santa for Christmas and he would say
oh oh on my lap and tell me what
you want for Christmas so Archie said to
his dad papaya P can I have a tree this
year and dad says no I do not want a
Christmas tree yeah cuz it'll ruin our
forest this is the thing
so the kids hatched a plan Archie said
to Quentin we need to cut down a tree
and show daddy that Christmas trees are
the way to go for everyone let's go to
the edge of the White House lawn and
chop the Christmas tree so sure
enough they cut down the tree and they
get the help of the White House
electrician whatever that is
well antenna lights on if they go off
food you're good at this was so oh so
Archie asked the electrician the
electrician said sure I can do it I can
put lights on the tree I'm a goddamn
electrician that's what I do and so he
put the lights of the tree then they put
the tree in the seamstresses closet
trees in the closet and the month of the
socket and they said we're gonna make
Papa believe in the trees
the trees make you believes the trees
make is nice below the knees cut to
commercial
what's your favorite Christmas song the
Paul McCartney song today that done
today that then hello
Christmastime right hmm what hmm
me what so okay so it's
Christmastime is exciting it's exciting
they opened up the presents and
everybody was happy with the presents
then Archie and Quentin said that's the
time to reveal the Christmas tree and
they open the door and there it is a
Christmas tree with lights and sure
enough the president says oh what a
great surprise
de appreciated the kids ingenuity but he
was also kind of like hey whoa this is
kind of like not what I said to do he
decided to call his good friend and
fellow conservationist Gifford Pinchot
Theodore Roosevelt said hey come on over
and give my kids the what for about this
Christmas tree
so everyone gathers around Gifford said
oh and ro actually if you chop down the
biggest trees it leaves sunlight for the
smaller ones to grow and there's less
all over the place well me so
President Roosevelt decides to lift the
ban on Christmas trees and everyone is
excited daddy so this means we can have
Christmas trees we're gonna have
Christmas trees
every year for eternity and from that
point forward he was a changed man
thanks in large part to Archie and
quitting those two little abouts
that chop down the tree
Oh God you little about Cheers my
Christmas we like to sing you a song
yeah see golden
[Music]
[Applause]
it's pretty good yep good one
double-click chip
[Music]